one of my favorites that i got to work
with as a matter of fact um
i probably did more nfl total access
shows with this man as
an analyst on that program than anybody
else
and he's a first-rate individual on a
pro football hall of famer rod woodson
how are you rod
what's going on brother how are you i'm
fine how are you
you there brock can you hear me richard
i can't can you hear me rod
i got you yes sir yes sir okay um
so um i mean let's let's start
i guess with um the passing of uh your
your friend and colleague and pro
football hall of famer kevin green
um rod i'm i'm sure this took you back
just like everybody else
well definitely did um you know i got a
text yesterday from
somebody in the front office from the
steelers saying that kevin pass and i
was like what
you know then a guy one of our teammates
called me and asked me if i
knew anything then i called the steelers
and
you know they told me what they know and
you know it's just unfortunate
guy 58 years old who's at home feeling
pretty good
for the most part and then you know he
said he didn't feel good for a second
and
um you know collapsing and passed away
so
uh you know what i remember about kevin
green is
when i first met him i was at my first
pro bowl
and i was on the punt team for the afc
he was on the nfc team
i was a wing guy and uh he
put his hands on me wouldn't let me get
off the line
i felt like a little baby kicking and
screaming
and trying to get down the field and he
was just laughing at me and saying wood
you're not going to get
not going to get away from me wood and
that was my first experience with him
and a great human being you know my
prayers go out to his wife and his kids
um he'll never be forgotten so
uh one thing to take from that story pro
bowl
he's playing like that in a pro bowl rod
for real he really did that
listen back in the back in the day we we
took the pro bowl very seriously
no that was uh we got a little got a
little extra change for
in our wallets yes and uh but you know
anytime you get competitors together uh
you want to have fun
you know you don't want to get injured
obviously but you know you want to win
right at the end of the day
you know back then he really took there
were some
pretty hard hits there were some you
know guys i think they're
extremely serious and if you brought
your uh your in-laws or your parents
you needed to win to try to break even
that's right i remember
that's right but the fact that again
kevin green is playing that hard in a
pro bowl obviously it was maybe more
prevalent back in the day but
he's just you know obviously you you've
got to be a certain competitor to get in
the pro football hall of fame what would
you want people
young uh folks who might not have seen
kevin green play know
about him and his style rod
well he was a tremendous player you know
a lot of people you know it took him a
while to get into the hall of fame but
you know he had done double-digit sacks
for over 10 years
and that's i mean getting 10 sacks is
hard to do for one year
he did it for over 10 years and you know
this is a tremendous player uh but the
one thing i really respect about him
is that he was a great family man you
know he was offered a job at the aaf
as a head coach declined it because he
wanted to be with his family
he left the jets because he wanted to be
with his
his kids uh in high school i mean
it was it was about family for him and i
respect that
tremendously because family is very
important at the end of the day
that's all we have and um you know he
he does he just exemplified everything
about
being a blue-collar worker because we as
in a society we praise
pla people who talk a lot of trash
and point at their backs and it's all
about them and kevin wasn't like that
kevin was just a blue collar hard hat
worker
came to play every single day and played
extremely well at a high level
for his the vast majority of his career
and that's the main reason he's in the
pro football of fame but
the long flowy hair yeah with the
strong attitude uh man i'll never forget
it
and i mean he you know i know he played
in other places but i mean
kind of the steeler mentality he he
personified it
oh absolutely i mean you know rich for
the first date i
the first time i seen him in person in
the steeler facility
he i walked into the weight room he was
his back was turned to me
i thought we traded for an office
alignment because he was that big
and he turned around and i was like
kevin
i didn't know you're that dog on big no
wonder i couldn't get away from you at
the pro bowl
you know so i mean it's you know he was
a stealer
through and through um you know he
played like a steeler
his mindset was like a steeler and the
great thing about playing with kevin you
know we had kevin green
we had greg lloyd so we used to call
them salt and pepper
anytime we wanted you know dom capers
our defense coordinator to put some
pressure on the quarterback we're like
hey
just give give that quarterback a little
spice
and as soon as we said that don would
call our saw dog
which is cover one but he's going to
bring the salmon to will which is greg
and kevin green and they would normally
always get back to the quarterback
salt and pepper and they mix it up in
the in the in the backfield and usually
would mean with some quarterback on his
backside
unbelievable rod woodson here on the
rich eisen show
let's talk about the here and now how
concerned are you about the steelers
right now
rob well you're definitely concerned
i mean three in a row um you know you
you play the first half of the season to
get yourself ready for the second half
of the season
uh and december you know losing three
straight games
is concerning and the way they're losing
is concerning
no running game they still got the
little quick short passing games but
you know anytime you're one-dimensional
and if you look at their stats the last
three weeks they are really
one-dimensional throwing the football
quick rhythm
take a couple shots down the field
that's what they've done but everybody's
kind of caught up to that
and if they don't get a running game or
a semblance to the running game
uh it's going to hurt them and you know
they you look at their last two games
they got the colts
in the browns so those are no give me so
it's going to be interesting to see how
they play
um you know obviously they're already in
the postseason but
if you can't get on a winning streak
going into the playoffs
um your mindset as a team somewhere
along the line
those guys that are on the borderline
are going to start questioning
should they belong um so you know mike
tom's a great coach i know he'll get
them back in order
but they got to find a way to get a
running game rich or it's going to be a
short playoff career for him this year
well uh my current colleague your former
uh nfl network adi king cable reporting
that mike tomlin
said today he's talk he's going to talk
to juju about dancing in other teams
logos apparently that helped
uh the bengals stir themselves up last
night
i don't get that rich i just don't get
it
i understand you want everybody to bring
their own uniqueness to the game
but the disrespect the logo is like a
sacred ground
you know it's it's that sacred ground
remember t.o try to do it
on the dallas cowboys uh logo and
after a touchdown i mean it's just
that's you can't do
stuff like that and i know it's a
pre-game but you just can't do it it
gives motivation
you're 11-0 at the time you know when
this whole thing's
when they at the beginning of the year
and then you're gonna
you're gonna get the a game from every
team that you play against
but now you're getting at you're giving
the team added motivation
to play even better and harder against
your offense and they've done that the
last three weeks
well i also remember tj houstmanzano
wiping his cleats on a terrible towel i
remember that too
you know i mean it's it's um you know
and and pittsburgh did not like that
at all i mean they still folks still
talk about that
you know and then uh but how do you find
it that's the problem how do you find
that run game i mean just hope that
connor gets healthy
or or and shows up i mean how
how do you find it so late in the game
and then you got the colts
you know with that defensive front
darius leonard and deforest buckner
followed by
miles garrett and olivier vernon then
followed by a playoff season
i mean this is this is dire straits
in a way rod right rick after you after
you just said that
it it it didn't make me feel too good
i just that's my job rod as you know of
working together i i just led
perspective that's my job is to lend
perspective
and on your opinion it is it is going to
be it's going to be tough for them rich
to be honest
um you know they haven't been a great
running football team
over the last couple years um you know i
love the story of connor
and what he brings to the table when he
is healthy
but that's the problem when he is
healthy and not only
about the running game but i think the
middle of the field
for the steelers and the linebacking
corps you know all the injuries they've
been ravaged with over the years or
excuse me throughout this year
you know they need to find somebody i
mean vince when he comes back
vince williams when he comes back that's
going to help them
but you know having all those injuries
from the linebacker when you're at 3-4
and your guys start going down and
you're missing your top several inside
linebackers
and the one thing that they exploited uh
quite a bit
the last couple weeks has been the
middle field and that's where those
linebackers roam
rod what's in here uh on the rich eisen
show a few minutes left with the pro
football
hall of famer so what what are you what
are you what are your two cents on the
final two weeks here
uh in this regard do you go with body of
work
last year into this year and just know
this team that has playoff hopes or is
at the top of
a playoff food chain like the chiefs or
the saints
packers that they that they are they're
fine
going into this postseason and they are
gonna be
actually the front runners or do you go
with a hot team
hot hand buffalo cleveland do you go
with the way the titans are playing
all of a sudden you look in the nfc and
you're wondering which team might be
able to catch fire
from that uh group where do you stand on
this issue
rod right now well i mean i think kansas
city is uh
the best team in the national football
league but when i you know i called the
buffalo's game last week in in
denver and when i when i'm watching
their tape over the last
over this year i'm saying if one team
can kind of score
point for point with the kansas city
chiefs it could be the buffalo beer
i mean they have weapons across the
board they can put up a lot of points
their defense
is similar to kansas city's defense
they're solid they're good
they're not great they've been
inconsistent but so is kansas city's
defense
so when i looked at the schedule i'm
saying
if we know kansas city is the best team
in the national football league
what team in the afc can put up the same
amount of points that they can
and the only team i can come up with is
the buffalo bills
and you know i i hear you i hear you my
my concern again and it pisses buffalo
fans off as i know because i see
comments um that um
that when it comes down to it can they
possess the football
maybe they could do it with josh allen
being part of that running attack and
then
just move the chains and let the let the
clock run down can they possess the
football
six seven eight minutes at a time
consistently enough
to keep the possessions limited for
kansas city
can they do that do they have singletary
and moss
do that for them is it alan mixed in is
it the short game with dawson knox and
cole beasley can they do that in the
cold
of cancer i guess they can right yeah
they can yeah you just think
so because mawson's signatory even
though moss is
about the same size as secretary
secretary is more of a scat back you
know
moss is a thick lower body running back
who
when he lowers his shoulder pads he's
getting
extra yardage he's moving the pile and
then they have a short passing game but
then you got josh allen in the running
game so they can go empty
they'll go quarterback draw that's a
called run they can you know get when
they get in the red zone that's where
it's critical
when they get in the red zone josh allen
doesn't make a lot of mistakes he hasn't
thrown an interception
in the red zone since he you know this
year
and he's rushed in his career he had two
last weeks so he has 37
or excuse me 24 rushing touchdowns
in his career young career so he's
capable
of adding to that running game and
anytime you can get
quarterbacks you can get you know first
downs with unscheduled first downs with
their feet
it just adds to the dynamics to it so i
think they could
beat the clock up but they're a big play
big strike
offense very similar to kansas city and
i just keep saying
if any team can score 30 points like
kansas city can on a consistent basis
it could be the buffalo bills and so um
what's the comp for for josh allen from
your
playing days is it elway would that be
the proper comp
for josh allen the way he's playing
right now you know too much
it's very similar similar i'm not going
to put him in the hall of fame category
no well he's he's playing he's playing
most valuable right now in a way but
what's the comp i mean for somebody that
big who can run
with a big gun who who's who's the comp
for josh allen
from your days well i gosh that that's a
that's a great question i don't know if
anybody that big
could run like he runs he can throw
he throws a great deep ball you know he
doesn't
when you look at you know dru lock who
has a strong arm when drew lock throws a
deep ball it's
more it's i mean it's a kind of a
straight line deep ball so he doesn't
give his receivers enough time to adjust
to it where
josh allen who has a cannon arm can
throw make any throw in the national
football league
when he throws the deep ball still he
gives enough air to his guys to adjust
to it
i mean this i can't really think of a
a guy who i played against who has the
same abilities
um you know because he's six six he's
245 pounds he can run you over
he can throw a touch pass but then he
can throw a bullet and he can throw the
long ball
so i mean he has all the tools in the in
the tool kit
um you know everybody kept questioning a
guy from wyoming can he
can he adjust the national football
league doesn't matter where you play if
you have talent
and once you have that talent you come
into this league you have a good system
and you keep getting better it doesn't
matter where you play so i
i think you know obviously he's one of
the better quarterbacks in the national
football league
and uh you know as he plays well they'll
keep winning
a couple minutes left when rod woodson
who do you like in the nfc who's your
nfc team
two weeks to go oh heck it's the green
bay packers how about that i mean right
now aaron rodgers is playing lights out
he is
i mean i'm not that the defense is a
little inconsistent
uh they can't make plays they can't get
uh some pass rush with the
the smith brothers but you know aaron
rodgers ways plan
and they're not running back you know
aaron jones you know
when you look at how good he is how
dynamic he is in space
in between attackers on the edges in the
passing game
you know and then if they ever get a
number two receiver rich
they're going to be dangerous you know
they've been trying to figure out who
can go
opposite of devante adams but you know
davonte adams
even he said it he's the best receiver
in the national football league
i i think other people probably want to
argue with them other receivers in the
league want to argue with them but
i think those stats speak for themselves
rod i love you man
um i always miss talking to you whenever
i do talk to you
um and uh you know it's interesting we
started with the pro bowl conversation
uh do you remember the advice you gave
me before i went to
cover my first pro bowl with you do you
remember the advice you gave me rob
back in the day i do not remember it you
told me you told me
out of whatever to do because you know
obviously i'd never been to a pro bowl
there in hawaii
you told me whatever i do the last thing
i should do
is give my room number to anybody
remember that
how do you remember that is true they
would take it and you there would be a
lot of my ties and
lava flows but you said you said you
said
you said forget about giving your room
number anybody you said don't even say
it out loud he said don't even write you
you told me
don't even write it down anymore is what
you told me yes
they get you they get you they what am i
gonna get my
rich eyes and mug and t-shirts and so i
can support rich eisen
well rod um todd get in line
you know what these guys are all looking
for well you know
he's looking for free stuff rod you know
mike you know mike's wearing free stuff
from when we worked together for the
first show together
that's how old that's how all this stuff
is that he's gone on right now
uh i got you covered i got you covered
like you used to cover the entire
national football league i love you best
to your family rod we'll chat soon
sorry take care talk to you soon the one
and only rod woodson yeah
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here